speaking of yourself not you said it's
hard for you not to look amazing that's
very true
that's very true and i will say you look
fantastic it's like honestly it looks
like somebody drew me it's like perfect
i look like a sketch you look like a big
sketch right yeah a great artist sat
down and drew and then here you are this
is what i am i'm a sex symbol when my
wife and i need alone time we tell the
kids oh we tell the kids that we're
going camping
yeah slang word for
i feel like everybody should look like
me yeah
what's the feature of yours that you're
most proud of you uh my cats
your cabs my calves are incredible like
i can't even describe them it looks like
two turkey legs like this
in a good way like the like the good
part like you have the amusement park
yeah you got like those big turkey legs
yeah that's my cast
your first time here tell us about
yourself i know you're from philly yes i
am jay uh i'm from philadelphia and uh
i'm a big deal people uh
i don't know
yeah
uh you know jay i'm quite sure you could
tell recently i've became a sex symbol
yes you look um
uh besides that modeling gigs are coming
left and right yeah uh baby gap called
uh
just tons of stuff man like right now i
can honestly say i'm like a kid in a
candy store i'm enjoying life uh i'm
enjoying where i am i'm enjoying my
comedy career so i said let me come here
on your show to tell people about it
educate y'all tell y'all how i'm doing
you know i'm living life right now it's
going well look at me
and he's thinking maybe get out of
football and become an actor um do you
have any advice for this guy of course i
got advice for kurt the first thing i'm
gonna say is kurt you're not gonna make
it okay let's just address it
shoot central intelligence
i'm shooting my video
while i'm schwein shoot his video your
video [ __ ] your video
no you crazy my fans will beat the [ __ ]
out your fans yo [ __ ] your fans i mean
you know your voice is important but you
don't know how important it is until you
lose it because you can't really
communicate and everything comes off
rude like you just look rude like when
you're talking to people
[Laughter]
you've always seen yourself as an action
star action star man i can flip uh i did
i did my own
nah he didn't want to do one stunt i did
i did one
which one i did the one i parallel
parked that car by myself
and uh there was one scene where i fall
out and i hit my head what are you what
are you talking about like you was in
there doing back-to-back stunts you
didn't do any stunts cute i did all my
stuff now you didn't missed it mr xxx
himself backed out let me tell you what
old
what old used to be action mode did he
came out tough no no no put the stunt
guys to the side i got it he did one
stunt threw him up against that wall a
little too hard didn't they the next
take cue was in that chair sipping
coffee i said
i said i said
what you doing man they doing a stunt
they hurt my back on the first one
[Laughter]
uh currently i live
in los angeles i got a i got a house in
cabo
and uh another house in miami oh god
damn little island just brought a little
island
yeah that was cool you know me myself i
i like walks
long walks new york i got one in new
york
um
philadelphia i got a place of philly too
um
jerk [ __ ] jersey i got one in jersey too
other than that man i'm just i'm a
regular dude i'm a regular dude we're
nice to meet you i'm just like yeah yeah
so just uh that's a little bit about me
no different from anybody else in here
i was a guy that everybody wanted to be
around because that was always a good
time now will on the other hand now let
me tell you about this now because i
know
you know
first of all you're looking at a new
version of will since the teeth he's
changed
we talked about this before but you've
had your driver's license taken away a
few times because of some infraction
like no i know i know you're asking me a
serious question i swear to goodness i
was in court today renewing my driver's
license again because it got suspended
i'm a speed demon you're a speed demon
i'm a speed demon i don't i don't
respect the law and i don't feel like i
have to because i'm a sex symbol now
when you do this
when my kid asked me for help on their
homework but i don't know the answer i
usually
say off
it's okay
i'm in philadelphia we're filming
untouchable okay um and i had a day off
so i decided to go to the sixers game
james harden is playing in the game and
the whole game the whole first quarter
he's just he's off and i was like you
know why you off because you're in my
city your beard stinks i hate you i was
like i hate your calves i told him i
said i think you got i think you got
butt shots i was saying a bunch of stuff
here and he got mad he said he said
remember all this he said i'm about to
cook you i said you gonna cook me or put
me in the pot because i'm ready to be
cooked
and we're talking like he's i don't even
know why he's paying me this much
attention
and at some point i was like james is
very unprofessional on your behalf
you're not even supposed to be talking
to me
james went on to score 55 points and
here's the bad part they beat us by 30
and with like a minute left he was
dribbling the ball and staying in the
half court and he was just staring at me
he goes
he goes tell your team what you did to
him and i said
i said you keep your mouth shut
rihanna was kicked off instagram for
excessive nudity people
[Applause]
tell you something else she's so sexy
that i would honestly pay a million
dollars to see her naked here's the
thing i've already seen it and i'm
willing to pay again
i would i would still pay for it you
were at the laker game last night i was
i wasn't like this game court sides
courts i got on the floor right there on
the floor i could touch somebody if i
wanted to
well
it looked like somebody almost touched
you because we here take a look at the
game last night
watch this there's you right there
almost in your lap
i understand something uh the reaction
that she saw just now there was an older
chinese woman to my i think she was to
my right yeah uh it looked as if i was
screaming you know probably out of fear
right it wasn't it was it was a chinese
lady watch out well that's what i'm
saying but it was here like i was here
with the chinese lady be careful yeah
nothing to do with me so i wrote a book
i didn't write a book i wrote a good
book
[Applause]
it is getting incredible praise on the
back of your book i'll just read one of
these many many quotes here before
reading this book i was an unemployed
loser sleeping on my mom's couch now i'm
living the life of my dreams all thanks
to kevin hart written by kevin hart
professional athlete
all the other praise comes from kevin
hart somewhat funny comedian kevin hart
award-winning actor and kevin hart life
coach and ladies man yeah those are
different different versions of myself
that gave the book the
i gave the book the just dude how did
you get them to write a blurb for your
book i just had the call of different
versions of myself
yeah i'm very good at going in third
person about myself kevin kevin thinks
this book is genius
me too yeah that was good but at the
same time like i said and me you know
i'm 56 years old damn
i'm sorry
i'm sorry because i it was a thought no
no seriously it was a thought
it was a thought and i blurted it out
that way i'm fine okay but just
understand i didn't mean it the way it
came
we'll take a poll on how you meant it
with people here later after the show's
over but i can sit up here and honestly
say buddy that that was from a place of
love got it
like damn you didn't if we could play it
back right now play back these are two
different dams playback in slow motion
there wasn't no i said i said there was
no like wow i said damn no you said the
word damn
do you want me to tell you how you said
it i know how i said it don't you want
me to say it back to you how i think you
said it go ahead
damn not not true fam not true fam i
said kevin i said
damn it
each time you said it now it's gotten
quieter and quieter i could barely hear
you that last time when you said it well
that means that you can barely hear the
truth
so who has the problem here
what's the problem
[Music]
a show where you sit in the hot tub
your body ain't that good you can just
walk around without your shirt off
if we're ever going to talk about bodies
i want you not to be the one to bring
that conversation
all right if you don't get out of here
shaped like a beanbag that got that in
whose idea was it for the fake pregnancy
well i mean when you're having fake sex
then you have fake babies
yeah well you know what you may have
been having fake sex on your side of the
bed but on my side i was tearing that
hey how come he didn't play in a
celebrity game this year man
you're the part of the party what else
do you want from me
mvp i'm in a hall of fame and celebrity
games it's over
it's over
i can't do it anymore i achieve
greatness shaq you know what that feels
like kenny i know you know what that
feels that's yes adam stop it right
there
dwayne johnson don't say it breath
smells like [ __ ] on the regular nobody
knows this you don't know where the
eyebrow rays came from it came from the
reaction of people when he goes hello
and everybody
that's what the rock is cooking shitty
bread
okay don't encourage him no my wife is
100 the fun police like when i'm when
i'm having fun
show up pull over you're having too much
fun
i was like back up back up yeah i'm done
i'm done man we
[Laughter]
he's uncomfortably drinking water
you know you know they had to create an
imax just for the two movies that he
made there's two
there's two movies all right okay yeah
yeah yeah you're going to the clippers
game this year i've gone to several
clippers games
how come you haven't mentioned that well
because hey you didn't give me a chance
to don't cut me off
i wasn't done i wasn't done you stopped
me and then you started doing some stuff
instead of several teams within those
several teams the clippers was in that
you would know that if you knew if you
knew talking if you knew about this
world you would know that that's what i
meant steve okay what you do is assume
that's your problem you
the assume are playing great balls
together
i think i think that the clippers are a
great place right now the guy gets me in
the front officer comes up puts me in
the front it's true story
one guy is always one guy in line he
yells out
why does he get to cut everybody
and i'm standing there right i'm just
standing there and i happen to look and
everybody in line is mexican and i was
like it just there's nothing i can say
to not look racist i was like uh
i'm famous and uh
i have to say
i don't see the steelers making the
place i don't know why you had to go
down that long road
to get there why why don't you have to
take 45 seconds of our life that we can
never get back
to say what you just said it was an easy
answer we all knew the answer why did
you take so long and i got to tell you
and another thing and if you know
anything about me i'm objective and the
thing about being objective is
understanding when to apply objection so
in this case i'm gonna go down a road of
objectifying and i'm gonna let you know
what you may not
the answer is no